Washington votes a national
correspondent Philip bump joins us
Philip good morning morning our ruff
transcript of the call between the
president and the recant Ukrainian
president essentially showed Trump
telling him he would be hearing from
attorney General William Bar what are
the implications of that being that the
Justice Department stood down on
investigating the whistleblower account
right well I think a couple of concerns
have been raised about that the first is
that those mentions of bar also come in
concert with mentions of Rudy Giuliani
who is working directly for the
president so essentially president Trump
is saying this is my team I have my
attorney general and also my private
lawyer both of whom are working together
on this issue the issue of course being
an investigation of his political
opponent now there are all sorts of ways
in which this raises questions about
Bars role as a lot of which have been
explored over the past few days but it
includes the fact that the Department of
Justice also declined to take any action
looking at this as a potential campaign
finance violations so there are all
sorts of ways which bar is implicated
that I think is sort of peaking the
House Democrats interest but there's a
difference in their involvement that's
still being sorted out what Giuliani was
doing versus what Barr was doing right
and that's exactly the question though
right so Giuliani working on behalf of
the president is one thing if he's a
rising lawyer exactly as opposed to the
Attorney General being test in the same
way this Ukraine is really as it become
this proxy war right not now just
between the Russia in the US but between
Republicans and Democrats yeah that's
true I mean the question here for
Democrats Democrats have there are a lot
of Democrats who for some time have
fought have sought a deeper
investigation in the presidents from
this has given them a mechanism to you
know sort of a rationale that didn't
exist prior the Republicans of course
are rising generally to president
Trump's defense however I think it's
interesting to note that the defense is
more muted than we saw for example in
the Russian probe in part because
there's still a lot of unknowns and I
think a lot of Republicans are a little
wary about jumping too strongly in
president Trump's defense with some of
these questions unanswered a Speaker of
the House Nancy Pelosi announced this
inquiry on Tuesday we see how quickly
things are moving what are the
implications for the Democrats and
Republicans is it a good thing if we
move quickly and we move on or do you
even see this dragging out obviously not
to the extent of the Russia
investigation yeah I mean the
Nancy Pelosi and other leaders in the
Democratic House caucus have expressed
an interest in moving quickly on this in
part to try and wrap this up fast Nancy
Pelosi has long been reticent to move on
an impeachment probe in part because she
just won the house last year she doesn't
want to lose that again next door she
does want to do anything which will turn
off you know people who might be willing
to sort of vote Republican next year
that's part of her concern I think she
wants to have this wrapped up well
before we start getting into the 2020
election cycle but you know the timeline
is you know it's not necessarily after
her quick answer if if if the house does
impeach but what does the Senate do the
Senate doesn't have to do anything
Mitch McConnell has said that he will
launch a trial but he can set the terms
of how long that is house if the House
Democrats want to drag up a lot of
information it's pretty much up to them
all right Philip bump thank you so much